I was thinking about you today obviously
very excited that you were going to come
in and talk because every time I talk to
you is it's a joy but there was this
quote that I came across that really
resonates with me and I'm sure you've
heard it but it's Aaron Paul and he said
that you're uh one of the most
professional people he's ever worked
with but you're also the most immature
person he's ever worked with and I
thought there is something about you
that beautifully is able to contain both
and I believe that I like to think that
I'm professional I'm also a complete
fool and somehow I think it's possible
to contain the the two at the same time
is that making sense to you I think so I
don't think they're mutually exclusive I
think you can be sincere and have uh the
things you want to set up in your life
and enjoy it don't take it too seriously
don't feel you're you're entitled to
anything
um you're very lucky and I think if you
flow with that you get a chance to have
fun and goof around
but I think you know I think I think it
it it depends on on how you were raised
and the the principles that you stand by
you know I really do I think it's you
know I tell actors all the time uh for
get your personal life in order if you
really want to be an actor you have to
get your personal life in order so that
you don't flake out
if you get your first job and you have a
nice big paycheck don't go blow it on
something put it away so that the it the
more sustain you yeah so the longer you
can um be an actor you know and make a
living in that's the best thing because
I think there are probably a lot of
young actors out there that think the
other way they think you know they there
are people that think in order to be a
great artist I must act like a maniac
because the tail wags the dog well it
doesn't no you know you just need to be
good at what you do at your craft you
need to keep it together but I think
there are a lot of people that that that
think that don't think that way you know
what I mean that think
um yeah I'm in my 20s I'm starting to
make some money uh you know gravity is
starting to lift everyone's treating me
really nicely uh it's time to [ __ ] up
well it's like especially with with men
men are just boys with that can shave
because
wow wow you really take that one on the
road yeah you really got to Sona on that
one soda how's the marriage
it's so funny yeah it was true because
because we're we're very uh we're
stimulated physically we see a car oh my
God look at that car yeah we see a
beautiful person male or female is oh
wow look at that look at these things
look at the gadgets look at when we we
sometimes act upon it uh we look at a as
a boy oh I want that chocolate I want
that thing I want and as men you have to
look at it and go I want that chocolate
but if I grab that chocolate I'm going
to feel such and such after I want that
woman but I am married and I need to not
do that you know you have to think of
consequences behind every decision
that's basically the difference between
a man a boy yeah the uh it's funny
because it it feels I know that I uh
I've known Bob Odenkirk forever and he
gives you a lot of credit for helping
him when he was starting out uh in his
role on Breaking Bad and he said that
you were very good at telling him you
gotta
you got to know your lines you gotta hit
your mark you gotta do the work
beforehand and that was your
introduction to acting for him was you
got to get your [ __ ] together before you
go out there and it's uh I've heard all
kinds of stories over the years in this
business mostly behind the scenes about
very well-known actors that don't do
that they they don't know their lines be
surprised yes and uh they're you know
they're hanging out in their trailer for
a while and not they're not just doing
the work and I think uh I think one of
the times that we spoke you talked it's
so much pride in the fact that you've
been a working actor
really your entire life for the most
part of your life and that you have
um and it's such a nice way to break it
down
because we can all get existential about
our career or where are we now you're
working you're working you're making
things you're you're you're paying your
mortgage it's it's a great way to I
think kind of simplify it well look at
you if you're lucky enough to be in a
business that you love to do a creative
one and you make a living
I don't want to hear a complaint out of
you exactly I don't want to hear that
you're you have to be here at six
o'clock in the morning we're acting look
at us so every job that I work on where
I lead the cast
I try to set that example so that I I
don't want to hear any complaints from
anyone there's enough artistic
frustration within that a joke's not
Landing this is not working oh we we
need to recast because this didn't work
out or someone you know there's enough
problems to deal with
you should not be dealing with any kind
of problems of I I don't want to be here
that early or how light do we have to
stay or some actors who don't want to uh
be off camera for another actor it's
like I I started that when I was really
young
um
Jennifer O'Neill do you remember
Jennifer O'Neill sure Summer of 42
beautiful beautiful woman and I I did a
I was a guest star on on a show that she
did called cover up was it cover-up I
think it was and uh
I had this big emotional scene it was
the day new moon it was the here it was
here's what happened here's why it
happened and how it happened and and
it's with her and we came back from
lunch and the director said
um Jennifer is still having lunch with
someone in in the commissary so we'll
just do your your side of it now with
with the script supervisor reading it
off camera and I and I said
it's a this is a big scene I wouldn't
mind if it was
just a couple little lines and not a big
deal not an emotional thing
but this is a big deal so I I don't
think so I don't I don't think we should
do that yeah and they said excuse me I
said no I I think we'll we should wait
for her then don't you think
and they said uh well you know I don't
know if we and I said no I think it's
important enough to wait for her to get
to get this right and so they had to
wait for her
that's great and you had again this is a
testament to you're very young at this
point you haven't
made it no I was you don't need seven
you're you're not Brian Cranston yet no
you're an early form of Brian Cranston
uh you're the beta and uh
and to say that because I
um I haven't done much work in that
world but what little I've done
um it it's immediately clear that you
know they shoot you and you're seeing
where you're yelling at me and then they
turn around and they shoot me getting
yelled at by you and if you're out for
that scene and they're just hanging a
tennis ball there they're saying pretend
the tennis ball is Brian it's very hard
to to do your your thing not really
because I Pro that tennis ball probably
gives you as as much emotion as I would
give you
and as much respect
I practiced this whole interview with
the tennis ball
it was good wasn't it yeah but we're not
speaking anymore oh yeah
the uh tennis ball is filing a complaint
canceled by a tennis ball
um that would be the lowest